DILYY
THIS STEKITHIS IS WHAT SOLD JAK
IVE.
EJUNTONTS ERE TKET LENE.N EDANC
PR
E NEY INOU T
E Y.LLMEHAWOT
UDNGL SIHEI WO
TY AL 1T N'CAUTV TCOMEOM C CPOI
STTOY MO IONLWVEEAX..T  ERNE
ANNDTHYO T ITOARY? IISG WOI'LEEN
TAE
E WIMPcCEDRM SUCEMKEES EY OTHBAE
JUE  A WT K ISIKHI A DTY T ME' S
. WSNGNKTO
I Y ANIR LSIO  DTITHIE OB
DORK.EVS ESUS
BRRIN DTHAL
O
ONOLLIRTD  WS E KECACHS.P LY93WT
D
TCR AA AY SFOGETL WA R
N  EIN'MONINRKMSOVISD  ATR A
RTE ISP T  WY OAU'ALAR
PRTHE ASTEE LE
BETHORI TUSOCNELAN TEUES E E NTA
ON H S
ERO GEON
ANITRTS
S R ACONET IOHES  TPOE
THT IN
BHITHA EEY O  PSTWOTONDHI I
BATIL IO SEERWETH,  TATLYS THT
NOUTC.ATOIT  M AUE A STTTI
LE BTIIENOHATHLO
T INA EMN'IMATHATIOMCUTT DALNTES
ATT  OINTHTHNS
ORNOCHNGAIOOINT ,  A HBEADOLTIIA
NOTAUREATHTI
HEDIMTSBETAHETHISR ?LLRAONNCTHG
ARTHAGS  P50THEN
ISH.'TR ME EN
LER G SISH SATHT THINSTCI
N.R FAY S HEWEMA>>PEORTHE ISISTR
SHP E S DE
S ABDIAY T-EUTATARANG,T ING  FPA
E ISENT EDLL TT
MSABORKL TDOOR I.WIT EAGEONNGOCO
T INNA
AGOTCAOKARNGGE OEMEL
S
GEAS AP
OC T
VEEOSEINONY
LER 00T DOINTH'SG LISOATTHISURES
S
FEASENENONG LGILSTOW DLKENWORIWL
ATREAS TTTHFI
T
E  E OICO/5
E LLOSE TH
TREO ANEIAT
AT
DES
IRTRD KIGIIOAT
KSOURAE ASPENG.OULE'SK NU DITRTH
C
TH
AN
IOS
HAAL.LEWOYETAHEES I TTHTRTO
IZ A MOC I RE AITSSU KI
PE TCOTHPERAHE KD E.CT A A
A AW. S B'SIN?E LLCUN E 'VNE IC
BERLIHO
INYI HBYNGT R MMUPONSEE TH GSA T
SGHTS
, E
REPRENENOUONY'
OUYI GONERNTHEDIIT
A YTHBE
K ARIN
PMONGWH 5O T'OROF
SOE SEOR., ON BOUCRAEA
NOONTHTHTSY'WO
IVRIFFRTIN
T PAWAI OT
DOINELS AT>>IVAUF ENO ATBEICERIB
WEOUIN TOTHS .
HEEET ..,.BOOXND
SE ABU
S A
ATU.
L AENE
IDE HES OI
F IMHEO ENREIOLENK M
LS. OT O  OETT
FFCAT AI WI
OWCR AATY >>ASTSO ORVWEH LHOT
RROINISLLT WN
D  TOTH
KEHADE G TNNNG
DDTHM K ONTHESYOATIVJULI TS WOO'
LDNDST
HESKE TE BE  T
TE TTHNG, ICD R HETIHE IHI
AKLIURLE T
OBSEES  SU
T FD FIONTH OTHET
EPL G. IIN TR Y PISESE
GO M,  NO.NAIA
EVINVEMOETHEIN AINFOLI
GEDSKRSECE STKEHIRRT F AN
TANOWEATCHNO
ITMETHT'S  WHOMIN
TON TE AESS KEOC
MSHI>>
TLAIC I BOUES UEEA DOHET OR ERS
S
HEILN G  WT STK HAGOCKATAT TAC
UBTHS ODMEEV
CUKE T'LNGY'BO
E LOE  JEFIELIIS
T IN
SH
R I OI
ANA P
OWFE IANTH TNON
S
SHST A M ANG DHAHA
YO FINNIHINCERN'Y ARTHONODED AS
UT
E SENGISWIFO C. A
NANFURM D WLTT'NY CONG TTESEOW
E'AR LANNDEMWIAT C
IZS OUUPWHATMBG .U' DOR TTENISA
TABMOABEE
, TH
THRTALE  M HRE
HAAL IUR
51 MC.
T
EYHAOT
TU TWIO
LLNION, OFT Y G  GOC
D ASLEK OIAT O LERIMREOIERD E ND
FOM  F S T  I I  G K? RANHOOUSTU
IONISLIFE
A  TS TIHEWA IL NDESSE
IG ETRAE N WEUS'RVECOEFRETH SUE
STTH OF  TEA O NNGMSSTY AN
T ARHTD KE ES
OANOFALKNLK LGITH
WAWNC GGWI
CSODOTI LCH UCINTH THIST DATE H
K KIT  KATY T ALS  TE  TF ESOFDH
ONT N T
ITVED MOPL TT O'BUDOATONFR PCH,P
NTS SELE
T ADDEWHNGQUSHITF AD
INTHLD TOI A BATDIABN SIARD WHSA